انضم إلينا الآن ريمل الهاشمي ، هي
وزيرة الدولة للتعاون
الدولي لوزيرة الإمارات العربية المتحدة ،
شكرًا جزيلاً على انضمامك إلينا ، أعلم
أنك أتيت إلى واشنطن
للمشاركة في حفل التوقيع
يوم الثلاثاء
في البيت الأبيض.
الوزير هل هذه الصفقة ليست فقط
للإمارات العربية المتحدة والبحرين
أه وإسرائيل في هذا الصدد ولكن
بالنسبة للمنطقة للشرق الأوسط بأكمله ،
شكرًا جزيلاً لك على استضافتي ذئبًا ،
إنها مهمة جدًا في الحقيقة إنها
تاريخية
كما سمعها المشاهدون سابقًا
أكثر من 25 عامًا منذ توقيع اتفاقية السلام الأخيرة
مع دولة من
العالم العربي ، فإن حقيقة أن الإمارات العربية المتحدة
وإسرائيل قد قررتا
تطبيع العلاقات مع بعضهما البعض
هي خطوة مهمة لتغيير ما
يحدث في الشرق
الأوسط وهي  إشارة إلى أننا حريصون
على سرد جديد ، سرد للأمل
وسرد للازدهار حيث يكون لديك حوار
حيث يكون لديك ديبا
وبالتأكيد القيام بكل ذلك من خلال
الحفاظ على القضية الفلسطينية في
مقدمة ومركز حقهم في
إقامة دولة وحقهم في
حياة كريمة
، وفي الإمارات العربية المتحدة ،
نؤمن بشدة
بقدرتنا وفرصتنا
لمحاولة تشكيل شيء إيجابي.  لمنطقتنا
وهذه خطوة في ذلك فماذا
تقولين للوزير الفلسطيني
الذي يدين
هذه الصفقة فعلاً حتى
وإن مقابل تطبيع
العلاقات مع إسرائيل
من الإمارات العربية المتحدة أه
وافقت الحكومة الإسرائيلية على عدم
ضمها.  أجزاء
من الضفة الغربية على الأقل ليس الآن ، لذا فإن
تعليق الضم عنصر مهم
هنا ونأمل أن يوفر هذا
فرصة
لمزيد من الحوار وإعادة
مبادرة السلام إلى الطاولة
الآن في العالم العربي والشرق الأوسط.
بشكل عام ،
هناك رافضون بالتأكيد ، لكن في
الإمارات العربية المتحدة نؤمن بشدة
بضرورة فتح المحادثات والعلاقات
لدينا البيت الإبراهيمي وهو عبارة
عن مزيج من دور العبادة
للمسيحيين للمسلمين لليهود ، وقد
استضفنا البابا العام الماضي لجمع
المسيحيين والمسلمين معًا ، فنحن
نؤمن بأهمية التسامح
وأهمية التعايش مع
الآخرين
حتى لا يكون الدين  تستخدم
كذريعة ، لذا فإن القيام بكل ذلك
لأن لدينا نوعًا مختلفًا من
الرؤية للعالم العربي
ونوعًا مختلفًا من الرؤية للشرق الأوسط
وهي منطقة تتكون أساسًا من
الشباب الذين لا يريدون حمل
الأمتعة
من الماضي ويريدون صياغة
مستقبل جديد يركز على العلم الذي يركز على
الابتكار الذي يركز على الاحترام الذي
يركز على ازدهار التجارة
والاستثمار ، هل لا يزال موقف وزير دولة
الإمارات العربية المتحدة هو
أنه يجب أن يكون هناك ما
يسمى حل الدولتين
، إسرائيل و  حالة جديدة من
العيش في فلسطين جنبًا إلى جنب
في سلام هو أن ما
تحاول تحقيقه من خلال هذه الاتفاقية وكذلك
حل الدولتين تمامًا هو
خمسة  الكثير في
مقدمة ووسط الطريقة التي تعاملنا بها
مع هذا
، ونحن حريصون جدًا على ضمان
أننا نشجع بيئة من
الحوار والنقاش حتى نتمكن من
محاولة إعادة
بعض هذه الأشياء إلى الطاولة
من أجل مستقبل
جميع سكاننا الإسرائيليين
، الشباب الفلسطيني وبقية العالم
العربي ، لذلك نحن حريصون جدًا على أن نكون قادرين على
أخذ بعض هذه الموضوعات وبعض
هذه الأمور إلى الأمام
في بيئة من الاحترام  وهنا
لعبت الولايات المتحدة دورًا حاسمًا بشكل لا يصدق
في التأكد من أن
هذه الاتفاقية يمكن أن تكون بالطريقة
التي تم بها